alerte associations recherchent
activement bénévoles une initiative
originale un speed dating était
organisée à versailles pendant une
dizaine de minutes chaque futurs
bénévoles a fait le tour des tables à la
rencontre des associations
j'avais une grande tente qui disait
toujours qu'il fallait se rendre utile
alors en ce moment je suis disponible
donc enfin je travaille que le week-end
et du coup je me suis dit que je pouvais
éviter de gâcher mon temps
chaque association possède sa propre
équipe de salariés parfois leurs
préoccupations comme la séropositivité
pauvres et freiner les ardeurs des
bénévoles
le bénévolat dans une association comme
la nôtre on va dire que c'est pas très
vendeur c'est compliqué effectivement
donc de s'intégrer parce qu'on parle de
sexualité et qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ne souhaitent pas parler de
sexualité mais effectivement on a des
gens qui arrivent à passer ce tabou et à
venir donc nous voir
cela dit on aimerait que ce soit
beaucoup plus après avoir fait le tour
des tables la chesnaie viennent à
stimuler les associations où elle
pourrait apprendre des autres c'est le
loisir avec des jeunes qui ont juste un
léger retard et la deuxième
on peut apprendre le makaton ou qui me
semble que c'est le langage des signes
avec des pictogrammes pour les personnes
qui sont non verbale qui sont pas
capables de parler
mélina qu'à rebours fera très
certainement le bonheur d'une
association dans les prochaines semaines
comme les 160 mille bénévoles du
département soit 10% de la population et
des noises